and puzzles be like [ __ ] like cold in
the apocalypse you know okay where are
you bet early uh la where are ya oh hey
I'll take this night yeah yeah surely
i'll keep it up I get all my [ __ ] first
okay I don't need any [ __ ] surprises
that's for sure take this let me take
these piers guys I love peas okay what
are you doing up here Ellie the chef
sure she ate here but this is here I'll
take this off ah god I'll take this are
they will the [ __ ] are you want to
explore somewhere so I don't like
trigger an action oh she just wanted to
the hell that mp3's okay the [ __ ] she go
now she's a ghost she's a ghost yeah I
should make something [ __ ] maxed out
now shut [ __ ] door stuck ok where the
[ __ ] are you and here betch I caught you
knocking hi Aniyah huh is this really
all they had to worry about boys movies
uh yes deciding which shirt goes with
which skirt it's bizarre get up we're
leaving and if I say no do you even
realize what your life means huh running
off like that putting yourself at risk
it's pretty goddamn stupid well I guess
we're both disappointed with each other
then what do you want from me admit that
you wanted to get rid of me the whole
time I did I want the salad ami knows
this area well I'm sorry I trust him
better than I trust myself stop with the
[ __ ] what are you so afraid of that
I'm gonna end up like Sam I can't get
infected its enormous how many close
calls have we had well we seem to be
doing all right so far and now you'll be
doing even better with Tommy
not her you know what Maria told me
about Sara Ellie your tread nasim mighty
thin ice here Oh ice I'm sorry about
your daughter Joel but I have lost
people too you have no idea what loss is
what is it everyone I have cared for has
either died or left me everyone [ __ ]
except for you so don't tell me that I
would be safer with someone else because
the truth is that would just be more
scared okay you're right
you're not my daughter
and I sure as hell ain't your dad oh sad
oh [ __ ] are going our separate ways get
it together we're not alone I've got to
walking there's more inside already I'm
gonna look around out here so check over
there hey betch i knows a [ __ ] in here
where yeah yeah yeah where you at [ __ ]
oh you like that cuz there's more where
that came from [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh that's
Tommy Jesus
and it hang back
yeah get him fit this [ __ ] to my eyes
closed oh yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
it's got this hour with betch sorry yeah
he's dead crotch shot like that like
that gut got it
alright house is clear that's easy as
pie let's get the [ __ ] out of here let's
get back to the horses I know the horses
have turned the horses I've turned we're
clear the thing is that being a zombies
you don't choose to be a zombie i guess
that choice in a born that way or not
yes I'm gonna hand up I got it this
[ __ ] is gonna fly this [ __ ] is gonna
fillet I could taste that [ __ ] fly
like a slick taste the [ __ ] future ok
sell her sup he's that
I'm eyestrain hell this throat over how
to test
no sad very sad
yeah not my daughter he loves saying
that sorry just get your minded like
you're not even adopt it like you're
nothing
I select chest there ain't nice here she
is kids be watching movies tonight where
is this lab eleres it's all the way out
university eastern Colorado ah cannae no
big horns
Hayley get off your horse you coming
back to Tommy I'm gonna hang on this
fellow that's all right here I won't
don't maim repeat myself what are you
doing your wife kind of scares me I
don't weren't coming after sorry for
stealing your horse come back to town
let's discuss it at least you'll me my
mind's all made up
University eastern Colorado how do i
find this lab it's in the science
building i looks like a giant marrying
you can't miss
take care of that web here there's place
for you here no
you good
okay ah dips out for her Amish